hey guys i'm ryan right phenomena we're
gonna check out the fallout 4 gameplay
trailer Aaron actually I found out that
he's like actually he's played you play
new Vegas yeah I play fallout new vegas
and before that I played fallout 3 and
outside of that I'm sort of a
johnny-come-lately to the Fallout
franchise I am aware of one in two and
tactics and Brotherhood stoom
so he actually knows something about
this game there's a last trailer review
I did I got a lot of hate for not
knowing [ __ ] about it how how dare you
not be aware of this thing yeah I even
set up from like I'm only watching this
cuz everyone's asking me to me I haven't
played but whatever it let's do this you
thank you absolutely now get ready and
stop hogging the mirror right and this
is where you create your character by
simply selecting part of the face and
sculpting such a cute nose oh wow
everything done here denovi yeah we're
gonna speed up time here and show you
just how easy and powerful this is to
create all new characters by just
sculpting and making changes wherever
you want in the face no series of
sliders that's amazing and it's cool to
use it you still can like adjust the
racial appearance of you carefully we
can deploy devious games mm-hmm still
complain as a female character however
you leave the menu ass is who you'll
play like how they chose to turn a white
guy in this new dynamic system it's the
same system we use to create all of the
games NPCs renovage even generate a baby
based on the couple you make
you can generate a baby based off the
couple you make
thanks guys away I like this this is the
best game playful nice cold I'm
wondering if like all containers are
gonna be like where there's an actual
model for the item in it instead like an
itemized list of what's inside of the
Von's 100 percent daily value of sugar
interesting it was like lifestyle in
here
reservations good morning
vault-tec calling vaulteq remind me
again why we're about you sir and
helping secure your future
you see vaulteq is the foremost builder
of state-of-the-art underground fallout
shelters vaults if you will a mother's
room for my entire family of course of
course of course naturally the wall
already cleared for entrance it's just a
matter of verifying some information
okay he's reset your stats it's called a
special system moving your dick bigger
that's heavy
just gonna walk this yeah they'll have
the endurance no strike or the thanks
again oh it's peace of mind that's right
the little paperwork right your
codsworth say my name that isn't for the
demo we actually have recorded around a
thousand the most popular names for him
to say sus because I can probably get it
important probably gonna choose like a
very rare name Just My Luck
couldn't generate on baby detonations
Castlevania my god oh my god what years
is supposed to be we need to get to
places like now the future as envisioned
by the 50s gotcha and then it goes 200
years after that into further in the
future after there's a huge nuclear war
that destroys it both of you
we'd love you to hold on now we're not
gonna be spoiling or talking about the
game's story tonight but you do survive
and get lowered into the vault events
transpire but you then emerge 200 years
later as the sole survivor a vault 111
this is the first time in the series
that you're playing somebody that lived
during the pre nuclear war era oh wow
yeah
because previously you played as people
that either live in a fallout shelter
evolve their whole life or into the
descendants of pre-war people or someone
that lived in the wasteland hmm so this
is sores that an enormous dynamic world
where you can create any kind of
character you want go where you want and
do whatever you want player freedom
remains our absolute number one goal
that ass this cat shape we're
got guys should have done more squats in
the boat yeah this is running on a
next-generation version of our creation
engine ok features full physical based
rendering as well as dynamic volumetric
lighting the last to follow games 3 and
new Vegas were running off a very old
engine called gamebryo so this is like
like the software underlying all this is
very like very new and up-to-date which
the series really needed yeah me sorry I
guess not so good here so other people
could still be alive - no no that's not
possible I wasn't after that long 200
years yeah what food yeah sure
I need a minute to thing right foods
good so I'm guessing there's some kind
of spaces guy on this vault is dynamic
is not a mode you're locked into you can
play it in first-person you can play it
in third person you can walk away
whenever you want you shoot him in the
face if you want
as like a Star Trek outfit yeah it's
like everyone inside those fallout
shelters has like the same yourself you
want to come with me pal
okay then let's stick together hey
head over there and yes you can give the
dog commands by simply pointing at
things in the environment activating
them it's all contextual grab that oh
wow
that's new like the way what you got a
handle in commands in the dog that's
cute man well it's that mole rat yeah
Jill mole rats
yeah hey baby
hey whoa bullet time into a mall right
we're the most ambitious and detailed
game world that we have ever made
culminating in the massive ruins of
downtown Boston Wow
you get ready say Boston's on its way to
look like that you know animate the way
that was Irish people are yes those
fresh-off-the-boat
Irish in Boston everyone in Boston is an
Irish national
yeah it really is the [ __ ] mood at
all it is so like you got understand way
to feel a haunting fallout 3 of all new
vegas have this kind of like weird green
and yellow
sounds like to see like vibrant colors
in a new Fallout game like a huge breath
of fresh air
but on a long walk to get to the top I
need to get to this bisque
that's specifically chopped cool man
yeah cool I mean I'm like I said like
I'm pretty much like being introduced
like reintroduced to this what how do
you feel about it I'm really done
because between this and some other
footage from e3 that I've seen it's like
this does more with adding to like
fallout mechanics than I could have even
imagined in previous in the last few
Fallout games you just kind of work
through the story and find a place to
settle down that's kind of like pretty
scripted by the environment in this game
you can customize and kind of build a
settlement all your own home just in the
environment with no bits and pieces that
are available to you which is insane
like New Vegas added weapon mods in this
game you can put a weapon together with
like practically like LEGO pieces to the
point that you can wrap a baseball bat
with buzz saws at the end of it if you
want incredibly detailed yeah you know
it's like they're just like all these
really cool attentions to detail or
there's this overarching awesome
attention to detail all throughout this
new version of the game like you do want
a power armor in fallout 3 and Fallout
New Vegas in this one you have to like
climb into the armor and this big
apparatus that opens up their engages on
the power armor you really feel like
you're in this big powerful suit of of
really high tech equipment you see this
is what I love about seeing and hearing
what you're saying is that they're
really trying to give you like and as
much as possible and immersive
experience yeah and that's awesome but
it also kind of like the way which
immersion is kind of being played with
in this game is interesting to me like
the way in which they're handling
dialogue in the previous games the whole
sentence that you can speak is just
spelled out on the screen you just click
on that and no word for word what you're
gonna say it looks like this is going
for more of like um I guess more like a
Mass Effect for lack of a better
comparison massive a kind of dialogue
system were using a choice what to talk
about yeah you said the gist of the
sentence and you can just sort of like
and you're just sort of crossing your
fingers hoping that that's close enough
to what you want to say but I'm down I'm
really excited and the release stages in
November so instead of seeing all this
hot [ __ ]
waiting a year this is coming out like
five months Wow yeah right right around
new years right around the Christmas
season yeah right around our 25th yeah
every Jewish person knows that everyone
knows what Christmas is a national
holiday
oh no it is it actually is a federal
holiday Jehovah's Witness holiday
Christmas yeah I actually don't think
Joe's witnesses celebrate Christmas I
don't celebrate anything yeah anyway
guys thanks for tuning in Thank You
Aaron for being here well I could be the
one being introduced I'm the clueless
gamer
and you're that knowledgeable one I've
known a thing in my day you have known a
thing and I have a thing sometimes my
thing falls out is the thing the thing
you were born with or is the thing to
strap on you said that you were going to
buy in the last video you can subscribe
to the real rejects you could check out
Aaron on the real rejects dank ass
Stubbs I'm sweating a lot for some
reason you check it out Aaron I put you
on the spot with the with a strap-on
thing yeah it was a joke between us dude
I'm sorry I'm sorry
no no one call me right now um so it's a
strap-on sale anyway yeah you can check
out Aaron on day cast Stubbs with Jerry
you false on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter and vine or if we get enough
followers a week and get product
placement for things such as don't know
I've used the stress ball many times for
things such as bananas bananas are great
they taste delicious they are nutritious
and if you're ever constipated using a
banana and putting it up your bunghole
that will not work it yeah it does are
you speaking from experience
yeah this isn't really like product
placement unless you're like naming a
brand of banana otherwise it's just kind
like a PSA no just to get people to know
you dumbass it's every banana company
like Chiquita and Dole and yeah whatever
they [ __ ] call every fruit company
yeah and the monkeys too in the the band
no like over the real monkey like in it
the animal the whole yeah the animal
how do you product place an animal tune
in next week